[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
estas imágenes corresponden a la plaza
de la libertad de la ciudad de gerzón en
el sur de ucrania y fueron grabadas
cinco días después de que el ejército
ruso tomara la ciudad sus camiones
tropas y tanques se instalaron en esta
misma plaza el pasado 2 de marzo gerson
fue la primera gran ciudad ucraniana en
ser ocupada el bombardeo había comenzado
el día anterior
hablamos con dos de sus habitantes y
esto fue lo que nos contaron
cumpleaños tiene vuestras
pero jim y cuando llegaron el primer día
comenzaron a bombardear el barrio está
briski este es el edificio 49 el 28 cayó
aquí en la calle tarle en el edificio 2
las ventanas estallaron el ejército ruso
impuso normas muy estrictas otra mujer
con la que pudimos hablar nos contó el
miedo constante en el que viven los
habitantes de la ciudad
estas son las reglas durante el día se
puede salir en grupos de uno o dos si no
disparan hay un toque de queda desde las
ocho de la noche hasta las seis de la
mañana si uno sale le disparan
sanz buey no se puede cortaron la
conexión móvil la gente no puede
llamarse entre sí contactar con sus
familiares llamar al campo
recortaron la televisión ucraniana
el canal
pusieron sus propios canales rusos el
primer y segundo día
llegaron camiones rusos desde tímea con
ayuda humanitaria
también viene un equipo de televisión
ruso
que filmó un reportaje en la plaza
principal de la ciudad
un hombre incluso intento hacer
preguntas sobre la ayuda humanitaria
pero se veía que era solo un montaje
[Aplausos]
animosa número esto los futboleros tal
vez pensaron que la gente saldría en
masa y se arrodillaría para pedirles
comida
afortunadamente eso no sucedió y no
resultó en nada
creo que no lograron filmar su reportaje
así es como esta misma escena fue
mostrada por 10 tea un canal de
televisión estatal ruso no hay rastros
de soldados fuertemente armados
solamente trabajadores humanitarios con
uniformes azules entre los gritos nadie
le hace ningún tipo de reclamar los
formatos
trichet y hay manifestaciones todos los
días de gerson y estas manifestaciones
demuestran que no necesitamos la paz
rusa no hay necesidad de salvarnos
no los necesitamos
en los observadores de france 24
seguimos muy de cerca la guerra en
ucrania utilizamos fuentes abiertas para
documentar lo que ocurre en terreno
hemos observado que aunque el avance
inicial de los rusos comenzó a perder
intensidad hay un aumento en el número
de bombardeos contra la población civil
queríamos conocer más sobre el tipo de
artillería que utiliza rusia el tipo de
bombas donde los cohetes que usa el
ejército y por eso consultamos a un
experto
cuando se observa en la estrategia rusa
hay claramente dos fases la fase inicial
era hacer una especie de élites que su
intención era conmocionar a los
ucranianos eso falló ahora están en una
ofensiva por etapas a lo largo de varios
ejes que están utilizando su potencia de
fuego contra las posiciones ucranianas
qué tipo de armas utilizan los rusos
vemos una gran variedad todo el espectro
de la potencia de fuego rusa
[Música]
los rusos tienen diferentes tipos de
misiles de crucero me pienso que
utilizan algunos de ellos pero se cree
que guardan muchos
suelen ser misiles guiados con mucha
precisión que pueden alcanzar objetivos
específicos
la mayor parte de lo que se ve sobre el
terreno son sistemas de artillería de un
tipo u otro el grande es un lanzador de
cohetes es la versión más ligera se
monta en un camión y dispara un gran
número de cohetes rápidamente
es un sistema antiguo que fue creado por
el ejército soviético y todavía se
utiliza
el smerch es un sistema de largo alcance
que dispara cohetes más grandes también
desde un camión
el este mes probablemente es disparado
desde belarús rusia tienen ese tipo de
alcances
ah
parece elementos han llamado la atención
en primer lugar por supuesto las bombas
de fragmentación son pequeñas bombas
distribuidas por artillería se extienden
por una amplia zona no se utilizan cerca
de los civiles pueden causar muchas
víctimas se supone que todas estas armas
se deberían utilizar contra objetivos
militares usarlas contra civiles es
ilegales pero como no son guiadas
explotan en las proximidades del
objetivo si ponen en peligro a los
civiles
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 si quieren
comunicarse con la producción del
programa los datos de contacto aparecen
en sus pantallas queremos agradecer a mi
la gastroplastia de bogotá por haber
sido nuestra locación en el episodio de
hoy nos vemos la próxima semana sigan
con frank 34